Thank you for listening to The Rest Is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That Samuel Slumkey to Mr. Perker. Everything, my dear sir, was the little man's reply. Nothing has been omitted, I hope, said the Honourable Samuel Slumkey. Nothing has been left undone, my dear sir, nothing whatever. There are twenty washed men at the street door for you to shake hands with, and six children in arms that you are to pat on the head and inquire the age of.
感谢您收听《历史余温》。如需每周额外剧集、无广告收听、抢先观看系列节目以及加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请前往 therestishistory.com 加入俱乐部。那是塞缪尔·斯兰基先生对珀克先生说的话。“亲爱的先生，一切都准备好了，”那个小个子男人回答道。“希望没有遗漏什么，”尊敬的塞缪尔·斯兰基先生说。“亲爱的先生，什么都没落下，什么都没落下。街门口有二十个洗得干干净净的人等着您去握手，还有六个怀抱里的孩子，您得拍拍他们的头，问问他们的年龄。”
Be particular about the children, my dear sir. It always has a great effect, that sort of thing. I'll take care, said the Honourable Samuel Sumkey. And perhaps, my dear sir, said the cautious little man, perhaps if you could, I don't mean to say it's indispensable, but if you could manage to kiss one of them, it would produce a very great impression on the crowd. Wouldn't it have as good an effect if the proposer or seconder did that?
“对孩子们要特别上心，亲爱的先生。那种事总是效果显著。”“我会注意的，”尊敬的塞缪尔·斯兰基先生说。“还有，亲爱的先生，”谨慎的小个子男人说，“也许，如果您能做到的话——我不是说这是必须的——但如果您能设法亲吻其中一个孩子，那会对人群产生非常大的影响。”“如果让提议人或附议人去做，效果不是一样好吗？”
Said the Honourable Samuel Slumkey. Why, I'm afraid it wouldn't, replied the agent. If it were done by yourself, my dear sir, I think it would make you very popular. Oh, very well, said the Honourable Samuel Slumkey, with a resigned air. Then it must be done. That's all. Arrange the procession, cried the Honourable Samuel Slumkey, with a resigned air. Then it must be done. That's all. Arrange the procession, cried the twenty committee men. There was a moment of awful suspense as the procession waited for the Honourable Samuel Slumkey to step out of his carriage. Suddenly the crowd set up a great cheering.
尊敬的塞缪尔·斯兰基先生问道。“嗯，恐怕不行，”代理人回答。“如果是您亲自去做，亲爱的先生，我想这会让您非常受欢迎。”“哦，好吧，”尊敬的塞缪尔·斯兰基先生带着一种顺从的神情说。“那就这么办吧。就这样。”“安排游行队伍！”尊敬的塞缪尔·斯兰基先生喊道，神情依旧顺从。“那就这么办吧。就这样。安排游行队伍！”二十位委员会成员齐声高喊。当游行队伍等待尊敬的塞缪尔·斯兰基先生走出马车时，现场出现了片刻令人窒息的悬念。突然，人群爆发出巨大的欢呼声。
He's come out, said little Mr. Perker, greatly excited, the more so as their position did not enable them to see what was going forward. Another cheer, much louder. He has shaken hands with the men, cried the little agent. Another cheer, far more vehement. He has patted the babes on the head, said Mr. Perker, trembling with anxiety. A roar of applause rent the air. He's kissed one of them, exclaimed the delighted little man. A second roar. He's kissed another, them, exclaimed the delighted little man. A second roar. He's kissed another, gasped the excited manager. A third roar.
“他出来了！”小个子珀克先生兴奋地大叫，因为他们的位置使他们无法看清前方的情况。又是一阵欢呼，声音更响亮了。“他跟那些人握手了！”小代理人喊道。又是一阵欢呼，比之前更加热烈。“他拍了拍孩子们的头！”珀克先生焦虑得浑身发抖。一阵雷鸣般的掌声响彻云霄。“他亲了其中一个！”那个欣喜若狂的小个子男人惊呼道。第二阵欢呼声响起。“他又亲了另一个！”兴奋的经理喘着气说。第三阵欢呼声响起。
He's kissing them all, screamed the enthusiastic little gentleman. And hailed by the deafening shouts of the multitude, the procession moved on. So Domini, that was the Pickwick Papers by Charles Dickens, which he wrote in 1836. Yeah. So that is four years after the Great Reform Bill had widened the franchise. Yes. And that is a description of an election in the East Anglian town of Eaton Swill, which is a very Dickensian name. I think it's based on Bury St Edmunds. And Dickens himself,
“他正在亲吻所有的孩子！”那个热情洋溢的小绅士尖叫道。在人群震耳欲聋的欢呼声中，游行队伍继续前进。多米尼，那是查尔斯·狄更斯在1836年写的《匹克威克外传》。是的。那是在《大改革法案》扩大选举权四年之后。没错。那是对东安格利亚小镇伊顿斯维尔选举的描述，那名字听起来非常有狄更斯风格。我想它是以圣埃德蒙兹伯里为原型的。而狄更斯本人，
you know, he'd been a parliamentary reporter and all through his life, he never stinted basically in his contempt for politicians, MPs, parliament, elections. And I guess that in that way, he stands at a tradition that's still going strong today because here we are in the midst of a parliamentary election. And we thought it would be fun to look at the history of election campaigns, didn't we? We did indeed. We did indeed. So the Honourable Samuel Slumkey, he sounds like a much more natural campaigner than Rishi Sunak or Keir Starmer.
你知道，他曾是一名议会记者，他一生中从未掩饰过对政客、议员、议会和选举的蔑视。我想，从这个角度来看，他代表了一种至今依然强劲的传统，因为我们现在正处于议会选举之中。我们觉得回顾一下选举活动的历程会很有趣，不是吗？确实如此。确实如此。所以，尊敬的塞缪尔·斯兰基听起来比里希·苏纳克或基尔·斯塔默更像一个自然的竞选者。
He does. So he's a bit hesitant about the baby kissing at first, but then he's clearly thrown himself into it. Oh, completely. Yeah. So he's the Tory in that. He's up against a Liberal. And he wins. Does Samuel Slumkey win? Yeah, completely. Yeah. So he's the Tory in that. He's up against a Liberal. And he wins.
确实。他起初对亲吻婴儿有点犹豫，但后来显然全身心地投入其中。哦，完全投入了。是的。所以他是那里的保守党人。他的对手是自由党人。而且他赢了。塞缪尔·斯兰基赢了吗？是的，完全赢了。所以他是那里的保守党人。他的对手是自由党人。而且他赢了。
Does Samuel Slumkey win? Yeah, he does win. Who's Mr. Pickwick favouring in this? Samuel Slumkey? I think they can't decide. Yeah. They're favouring whichever party of supporters they mix up with because the supporters are quite violent.
塞缪尔·斯兰基赢了吗？是的，他赢了。匹克威克先生在这件事上支持谁？塞缪尔·斯兰基吗？我想他们无法决定。是的。他们支持任何他们混入其中的政党，因为支持者们相当暴力。
Of course they are. Which is basically the theme of today's episode, isn't it? It is the theme of today's episode. Yeah. Because elections were so, I mean, in Dickens' time, elections were so colourful. And the Pickwood paper is probably the most famous description of an election. That's sort of carnival-esque. There's booze, there's ribbons, there's crowds, there's babies.
当然他们是。这基本上就是今天这一集的主题，不是吗？这确实是今天这一集的主题。是的。因为在狄更斯的时代，选举非常丰富多彩。《匹克威克外传》可能是对选举最著名的描述。那简直就像一场嘉年华。有酒、有丝带、有人群、有婴儿。
It's like a huge public event and great excitement. And it's great fun. I think it's much more fun than a modern election, don't you? I mean, there is an element of management, but it's not as bland as a modern election. I mean, the electorate is smaller, even with the Great Reform Act, which widens the franchise. And so that means there can be much more targeted bribery. They can, yeah. So I think if you're a voter, that must make it more fun.
这就像一场巨大的公共活动，非常令人兴奋。而且非常有趣。我觉得这比现代选举有趣得多，你不觉得吗？我的意思是，虽然有管理的成分，但它不像现代选举那样平淡。我的意思是，选民人数较少，即使在《大改革法案》扩大了选举权之后也是如此。这意味着可以进行更有针对性的贿赂。他们可以，是的。所以我认为如果你是选民，那一定会让选举更有趣。
There's bribery, there's enormous hooliganism, which we're getting stuck into. Lots of beer. Yeah. And there's also people being shot in the face. Okay, that's less fun if you get shot in the face that's right but we're going to be getting onto that in due course so we thought we'd do this episode about the sort of the riotous history of general elections so general elections in the more distant past and then we'll do one on more recent elections so today's is the deep history isn't it the deep history so um do you know what The first elections are actually quite old.
有贿赂，有巨大的流氓行为，我们正要深入探讨。有很多啤酒。是的。还有人脸部中弹。好吧，如果脸部中弹那就不太有趣了，没错，但我们稍后会谈到这一点。所以我们想做这一集关于大选骚乱历史的内容，也就是遥远过去的大选，然后我们再做一集关于近期选举的。所以今天讲的是深层历史，对吧？深层历史。所以，你知道吗，第一次选举其实相当古老。
So the first parliament, people, when they talk about parliament, they say, well, the first parliament was 1236, 1237. But there's no commons in that parliament. So that's basically a gathering of barons approving taxes. You probably get the first elections as early as 1265. And actually, it's called Simon de Montfort's parliament. So Simon de Montfort's the so simon de montfort's the kind of overmighty baron who challenges henry iii he ends up castrated yes he does
所以，当人们谈论议会时，他们会说，嗯，第一次议会是在1236年或1237年。但那个议会里没有平民院。所以那基本上是一群男爵在批准税收。你可能在1265年才有了第一次选举。实际上，它被称为西蒙·德·蒙福尔议会。所以西蒙·德·蒙福尔是那种权势过大的男爵，他挑战了亨利三世，最后被阉割了，是的，确实如此。
uh it's good to get that in early he basically summons a parliament a big council of people to approve his policies and a parliament is where people talk ballet yes exactly and he's unusual he gets the nobility and the churchmen but but he also gets burgesses. So basically town bigwigs, but commoners from all the major towns. So York and Lincoln and so on and summons them to London. And we don't know how they were basically chosen because they would do Simon de Montfort's bidding. But that principle of the major town, people will actually choose somebody to represent them in London and agree to taxes. And even then it's about taxes, right? It's always about taxes. So that's why when we did our series on the American Revolution, that's at the heart of the American Revolution. So on the one hand, you have people who say, listen, Parliament has always had the right to levy taxes. That is one of the cornerstones, if you can have multiple cornerstones, of the English constitution. And on the other hand,
嗯，早点提到这一点很好。他基本上召集了一个议会，一个由大批人组成的委员会来批准他的政策，而议会就是人们讨论的地方，是的，完全正确。他不寻常的地方在于，他不仅召集了贵族和教会人士，还召集了市民。也就是城镇里的头面人物，但也是来自所有主要城镇的平民。比如约克、林肯等等，并把他们召集到伦敦。我们不知道他们是如何被选出来的，因为他们会听从西蒙·德·蒙福尔的命令。但主要城镇的人们实际上会选择某人代表他们在伦敦并同意税收的原则，即使在当时也是关于税收的，对吧？总是关于税收的。所以这就是为什么当我们做关于美国革命的系列节目时，那是美国革命的核心。所以一方面，有些人说，听着，议会一直有权征税。这是英国宪法的基石之一，如果你可以有多个基石的话。而另一方面，
you have the American revolutionaries who say, hey, but the point is the town sends somebody to parliament and we haven't sent anybody. No taxation without representation. Exactly. So taxation is always there, but this idea that people will be chosen somehow in some obscure way. And actually the truth of it is that from that point onwards, all the way through to, let's say, the dawn of political parties. So that's the reign of Charles II and then his successors, the Whigs and the Tories. So in that intervening period, which is what, 400 years or so, we don't actually really know how people were chosen. It's very confused. It's very confused. It's very mysterious.
你有美国革命者说，嘿，但重点是城镇派人去议会，而我们没有派任何人。无代表，不纳税。完全正确。所以税收一直都在，但这种人们会以某种模糊方式被选出的想法。事实上，从那时起，一直到政党政治的黎明。也就是查理二世及其继任者的统治时期，辉格党和托利党。所以在那个中间时期，也就是大约400年左右，我们其实并不知道人们是如何被选出来的。非常混乱。非常混乱。非常神秘。
Basically, what will happen is every now and again, the king will send a writ to two different places, to the counties and to the boroughs. And he'll say, I want you to send two MPs to parliament. And how they choose them, there's no law. There's no set rules. So it's basically local custom that determines it. And actually, you would think that people are always saying, oh, let's have open contests, let's have more and more people choosing. But no, not at all. The gist of it is people say, well, too many people are choosing. I was just thinking about that. The idea that
基本上，每隔一段时间，国王就会向不同的地方，向郡和自治市镇发送令状。他会说，我希望你们派两名议员去议会。至于他们如何选择，没有法律。没有既定规则。所以基本上是当地习俗决定了这一点。而且实际上，你可能会认为人们总是说，哦，让我们进行公开竞争，让我们有越来越多的人参与选择。但完全不是。其要点是人们说，嗯，选择的人太多了。我刚才就在想这个。那种认为
shrinking the electorate is democratic. This is my policy, Tom. But if you think today, there's arguments of arguments about how party leaders are chosen. Yeah. And at the moment, it's party members and it's not the MPs. And there's a real movement to say actually it should just be MPs
缩小选民范围是民主的想法。这是我的政策，汤姆。但如果你想想今天，关于如何选择政党领袖的争论。是的。目前是党员，而不是议员。而且有一种真正的运动说，实际上应该只是议员，
because party members are all mad by definition because they're party members. Yeah, who joins a political party? So they shouldn't be allowed anywhere near an election. Exactly. So it's a bit like that, isn't it?
因为党员按定义都是疯子，因为他们是党员。是的，谁会加入政党呢？所以他们不应该被允许靠近选举。完全正确。所以这有点像那样，不是吗？
It is a bit. So in 1429, I read, there's a brilliant essay on this by a guy called Neil Johnston from the House of Commons It is a bit. So in 1429, I read, there's a brilliant essay on this by a guy called Neil Johnston from the House of Commons Library. And he says that in 1429, the Commons actually presented a petition to the king, to King Henry VI.
确实有点像。所以我在1429年读到，有一个由下议院图书馆的尼尔·约翰斯顿撰写的精彩文章。他说在1429年，平民院实际上向国王，亨利六世国王提交了一份请愿书。
And they said, an excessive number of people are deciding who their MPs are. And the greater part of these people are people of little or no means. And these people pretend to have an equivalent voice as the most worthy knights or esquires dwelling in the same counties. In other words, like upstarts, people have no consequence, Tom. Yeah. Well, do you know, Dominic, whenever I read about kind of medieval or early modern elections, I always think they sound much more fun and that we should go back to organizing like that. Definitely much better. So there sort of emerges a consensus that basically you don't get to vote really unless you own a freehold.
他们说，决定议员人选的人数过多。而这些人中的大部分是几乎没有财产的人。这些人假装拥有与居住在同一郡中最有价值的骑士或乡绅同等的发言权。换句话说，就像暴发户，没有地位的人，汤姆。是的。嗯，你知道吗，多米尼，每当我读到关于中世纪或近代早期选举的内容时，我总是觉得它们听起来更有趣，我们应该回到那种组织方式。绝对好得多。所以出现了一种共识，基本上除非你拥有自由保有权，否则你真的不能投票。
So you have property worth 40 shillings or more in land in a particular place. And Dominic, that might mean that a woman could vote. Right. Well, this is a fascinating thing. So under the Tudors and the Stuarts, it is perfectly possible. We don't know for sure, but it is possible that women could have voted. Where it worked was in places where people were suspicious of a woman voting, she would
所以你在特定地方拥有价值40先令或以上的土地财产。多米尼，那可能意味着女性可以投票。对。嗯，这是一件令人着迷的事情。在都铎王朝和斯图亚特王朝时期，这完全是有可能的。我们不能确定，但女性确实有可能投票。在人们怀疑女性投票的地方，她会
take a lodger and basically he would vote for her or she would lend her vote to somebody in some way. So there's that. So first of all, it's not certain that it was actually just men. So you've got two kinds of seats, counties and boroughs. And in the counties, we've said you have to have property worth 40 shillings. Now in a borough, it is totally random. So that's basically a town.
找一个房客，基本上他会替她投票，或者她会以某种方式把选票借给别人。所以有这种情况。所以首先，不能确定当时真的只有男性。所以你有两种席位，郡席位和自治市镇席位。在郡里，我们说过你必须拥有价值40先令的财产。而在自治市镇，这完全是随机的。所以那基本上是一个城镇。
It's completely mad and random. Well, as someone from Salisbury, Sarum. Yeah. New Sarum, but we have old Sarum outside it. Yeah. It's the most famous of all rotten boroughs. Well, we'll get to rotten boroughs in a second. Oh, sorry.
这完全是疯狂和随机的。嗯，作为一个来自索尔兹伯里、萨勒姆的人。是的。新萨勒姆，但我们外面有老萨勒姆。是的。它是所有腐败选区中最著名的一个。嗯，我们一会儿会谈到腐败选区。哦，抱歉。
I'm jumping the gun here. That's all right. But it's my over-excitement at the fact that Salisbury is going to feature it. Of course. I know you love Wiltshire and the Salisbury area generally. There's no question about that. So here are some fun complications. So first of all, there are boroughs that are called Scott and Lott boroughs.
我操之过急了。没关系。但这只是因为我太兴奋了，因为索尔兹伯里要出现在节目里了。当然。我知道你喜欢威尔特郡和索尔兹伯里地区。这一点毫无疑问。所以这里有一些有趣的复杂情况。首先，有一些被称为“斯科特和洛特”选区的自治市镇。
Brilliant. So Tom, this is a borough where you're liable to a Scott of a Lott. I think that clarifies. Of course. That clarifies things. Okay. What does that mean? So a Scott is like a payment and a lot is a share.
太棒了。所以汤姆，这是一个你需要承担“斯科特和洛特”责任的选区。我想这解释清楚了。当然。这解释清楚了。好吧。那是什么意思？所以“斯科特”就像一种付款，“洛特”就是一份份额。
So it's not if you keep a Scotsman? No, this is a very bad thing, a Scot of a lot, because it means you have to pay a share of the local church and poor relief tax rates. So then you get to vote. I wouldn't mind doing that. Compassionate person. Then there's a pot walloper borough, right? And a pot walloper borough, you're a householder.
所以这不是如果你养一个苏格兰人？不，这是一个非常糟糕的事情，斯科特和洛特，因为它意味着你必须支付当地教会和贫困救济税率的一部分。然后你就可以投票了。我不介意那样做。富有同情心的人。然后还有一种“锅墙”选区，对吧？在锅墙选区，你是一个户主。
You're not on welfare. You're not on welfare. You're not on benefits. They don't make any claim on poor relief. And you have your own hearth on which you can wallop a pot. A pot. And that means to boil a pot. Do you have to wallop a pot? Is this kind of part of the ritual, part of the election fun? You get out your pot and wallop it. You have to demonstrate that you can boil a kettle. Yeah, exactly. Then slightly more boringly, there's corporation boroughs. So this basically is very corrupt. This is where the corporation of a town, the people who are basically the town council or whatever, they choose the MPs and they can give no consideration whatsoever to the residents. And there, the corporation is self-sustaining. So in other words, it's like a closed oligarchy. When somebody dies or whatever, the corporation effectively
你没有领救济金。你没有领救济金。你没有领福利。他们不对贫困救济提出任何要求。而且你有自己的炉灶，可以在上面煮一锅东西。一锅。这意味着煮一锅东西。你必须煮一锅东西吗？这是仪式的一部分，选举乐趣的一部分吗？你拿出你的锅煮它。你必须证明你能烧开水。是的，完全正确。然后稍微无聊一点的是公司选区。所以这基本上是非常腐败的。这是城镇的公司，基本上是镇议会或类似机构的人，他们选择议员，他们可以完全不考虑居民。在那里，公司是自我维持的。所以换句话说，它就像一个封闭的寡头政治。当有人去世或发生什么事时，公司实际上
choose who replaces them. So if you have somewhere like, the good example is Tiverton. It's Devon, isn't it, Tiverton? Yeah, it is in Devon. So there, before the Great Reform Act that you mentioned at the beginning, there were 10,000 residents, but only 25 of them could vote, and they were the corporation. And basically, the corporation usually did the bidding
选择谁来接替他们。所以如果你有像蒂弗顿这样的地方，很好的例子是蒂弗顿。那是德文郡，对吧，蒂弗顿？是的，它在德文郡。所以那里，在你开头提到的《大改革法案》之前，有10,000名居民，但只有25个人可以投票，他们就是公司成员。基本上，公司通常听从
of the local landowner. So that's a corporation borough. And then my favourite of all these complicated bidding of the local landowner. So that's a corporation borrower. And then my favorite of all these complicated things is the faggot vote. So this will be of interest to our American listeners. It definitely will be. So the faggot vote, basically what happens there is you, Tom Holland, own a 40-shilling freehold. You own some land in Wiltshire, let's say.
当地地主的命令。所以这就是一个公司选区。然后我最喜欢所有这些复杂事情中的一个是“柴火选票”。所以这对我们的美国听众会很有趣。绝对会。所以“柴火选票”，基本上发生的事情是你，汤姆·霍兰，拥有一个40先令的自由保有权。你在威尔特郡拥有一些土地，比如说。
Right. You know, you're rewilding some land in Wiltshire, Tom, for example. Yeah. And that would give you a vote. Now, you might subdivide your land up into parcels and sell them off and say, these are all 40 shilling freeholds, but you would basically do a deal with the people who buy them. You're creating more voters, but they will vote as you instruct them. Brilliant. I'm all in favour of that.
对。你知道，你在威尔特郡重新野化一些土地，汤姆，例如。是的。那会给你一张选票。现在，你可能会把你的土地细分成小块并卖掉，说这些都是40先令的自由保有权，但你基本上会与购买它们的人达成协议。你创造了更多的选民，但他们会按照你的指示投票。太棒了。我完全赞成。
So that was outlawed by the Splitting Act of 1696, where people ignored that and carried on creating faggot voters. Woke tosh. That's the bulldog spirit. Exactly. So this is the kind of stuff that maybe reform could bring back in. Right, yes. Properly turn the clock back to a more organic voting system that better reflects the sensibilities of the British people. The organic traditions of the mother of parliament.
所以这在1696年的《拆分法案》中被取缔了，但人们无视这一点，继续创造柴火选民。觉醒派的废话。这就是斗牛犬精神。完全正确。所以这就是那种也许改革可以带回来的东西。对，是的。适当地把时钟拨回到一个更有机的投票系统，更好地反映英国人民的感性。议会之母的有机传统。
Exactly. Also, just to ask, don't Oxford and Cambridge have MPs as well? Yes, they do. They're the only ones, only universities. But that goes right the way up, I think, to the 20th century. Yes, to the Second World War thereabouts, I think that Oxford and Cambridge had MPs. I mean, that is mad. Now, you mentioned Rotten Burrows and Old Sarum. So for people who don't know, what is Old Sarum? So Old Sarum is an Iron Age hill fort, and then it became a Roman town, and then it became an Anglo-Saxon centre for moneyers, so coining, and then it became a Norman stronghold. And they built the first Salisbury Cathedral there, but it wasn't very convenient because it didn't have water
完全正确。另外，顺便问一下，牛津和剑桥也有议员吗？是的，他们有。他们是唯一的，唯一的大学。但我认为这一直持续到20世纪。是的，直到第二次世界大战左右，我想牛津和剑桥都有议员。我的意思是，这太疯狂了。现在，你提到了腐败选区和老萨勒姆。所以对于不知道的人，什么是老萨勒姆？所以老萨勒姆是一个铁器时代的堡垒，然后它变成了一个罗马城镇，然后它成为了盎格鲁-撒克逊的铸币中心，也就是铸币，然后它成为了诺曼人的据点。他们在那里建造了第一座索尔兹伯里大教堂，但它不太方便，因为它没有水
supply. So basically there were limitations to how large it could grow. And so they moved down to where the cathedral currently stands, the new cathedral. Yeah. And Old Sarum was kind of left as a historical antiquity. So Constable famously painted it. So it's basically like a dead town, like a ghost town almost. It's not even that. There's nothing there.
供应。所以基本上它能长多大是有限制的。所以他们搬到了现在大教堂所在的地方，新大教堂。是的。而老萨勒姆被当作一种历史古迹留了下来。所以康斯特布尔著名地画了它。所以它基本上就像一个死城，几乎像一个鬼城。甚至连那都算不上。那里什么都没有。
Yeah, there's very little there. I mean, it's kind of chunks of castle or whatever, but the cathedral has completely vanished. You can just see the outline. Yeah. It's fabulous. So Old Sarum, when it was a thing, Old Sarum had been given the right to send two MPs to Parliament in 1295.
是的，那里几乎什么都没有。我的意思是，它有一些城堡的残骸之类的，但大教堂已经完全消失了。你只能看到轮廓。是的。太棒了。所以老萨勒姆，当它还是个东西的时候，老萨勒姆在1295年被赋予了向议会派遣两名议员的权利。
But obviously it declines and declines and declines. But when you've got that right, you never lose it. Right. So basically there's nobody living there, but they're still sending two MPs. And this is obviously demented, but you can't change it, Tom. Well, you say that, but why do you hate Britain, Dominic? Yeah. So there's a wonderful description of the election in 1802. The election was held in a booth
但显然它衰落了，衰落了，又衰落了。但当你拥有那种权利时，你永远不会失去它。对。所以基本上那里没有人住，但他们仍然在派遣两名议员。这显然是精神错乱，但你不能改变它，汤姆。嗯，你这么说，但你为什么讨厌英国，多米尼？是的。所以有一段关于1802年选举的精彩描述。选举是在一个摊位举行的
in a cornfield under a tree, which marked the former boundary of the town. I think this is everything about Mary England, and I'm amazed you're against it. And the source says, not a vestige of which the town has been standing in the memory of man being now without a dwelling for a human being. So there are five electors. They are the Reverend Dr. Skinner, the Reverend Mr. Burrow, Mr. William Dyke, Mr. Massey, and Mr. Brunsden. The Reverend Skinner nominates two potential MPs, and he says their conduct will give satisfaction
在玉米地里的一棵树下，这标志着城镇以前的边界。我认为这就是关于古老英格兰的一切，我很惊讶你反对它。资料来源说，在人类记忆中，城镇的任何痕迹都没有留下，现在没有一个人类居住的地方。所以有五名选民。他们是斯金纳博士牧师、伯罗先生牧师、威廉·戴克先生、马西先生和布伦斯登先生。斯金纳牧师提名了两名潜在的议员，他说他们的行为会给选民带来满足感
to honour to their constituents, who don't really exist. Well, the five of them do. Now, the other electors agree to this, the other four people. They say, brilliant, let's send these two guys. And they get two MPs. This is in an era when Manchester has no MPs at all. Yeah, well, I think sensible policies for a happier Britain. Now, this election, which is very Pickwickian, very Dickensian, this was actually being controlled.
给他们的选民带来荣誉，而这些选民并不真正存在。好吧，他们五个人确实存在。现在，其他选民同意这一点，其他四个人。他们说，太棒了，让我们派这两个家伙去。他们得到了两名议员。这还是在曼彻斯特根本没有议员的时代。是的，嗯，我认为这是为了一个更幸福的英国而采取的明智政策。现在，这次选举，非常匹克威克式，非常狄更斯式，实际上是被控制的。
It had been bought by the Earl of Caledon. He had bought the land and basically he had installed the electors and he is supposed to have paid £60,000 for it. And that's the equivalent. I checked at their website measuring worth, which is kind of academic calculator. That's the equivalent of about £80 million today. So in other words, he's a super rich magnate who has paid £80 million for two MPs. Now he has them in his pocket. Yeah, now he has them in his pocket, exactly. But I mean, obviously our subject is elections.
它被卡利登伯爵买下了。他买下了土地，基本上他安插了选民，据说他为此支付了6万英镑。这相当于。我在他们的网站Measuring Worth上查过，那是一种学术计算器。这相当于今天大约8000万英镑。所以换句话说，他是一个超级富有的巨头，为两名议员支付了8000万英镑。现在他把他们装进了口袋。是的，现在他把他们装进了口袋，完全正确。但我的意思是，显然我们的主题是选举。
There are lots of proper elections because at the point where you get party politics, so the Whigs and the Tories, and we can go on to talk a little bit maybe about what the Whigs and the Tories are, there are probably about 200,000 people who can vote. So there are 200,000 of these freeholders and whatnot. And there's a brilliant, brilliant online project done by the University of Newcastle on 18th century political culture. And there's an opening essay by Dr. Hilary Burlock, which lays out exactly how an 18th century or late 17th election would work. So basically, Parliament is dissolved and the Lord Chancellor sends out writs for a new Parliament. And it's a very sort of chaotic and confused picture because the elections are decided
有很多正规的选举，因为在政党政治出现的时候，也就是辉格党和托利党，我们可以继续谈谈辉格党和托利党是什么，大约有20万人可以投票。所以有20万这些自由持有者之类的。有一个由纽卡斯尔大学做的关于18世纪政治文化的精彩在线项目。希拉里·伯洛克博士有一篇开篇论文，准确地列出了18世纪或17世纪末的选举是如何运作的。所以基本上，议会解散，大法官发出新议会的令状。这是一个非常混乱和困惑的画面，因为选举是由
kind of locally and they can happen at different times and often they can happen over different days. So it's a big nominating meeting. And if there are more than two candidates, then basically everyone's like, yes, we're going to have an election. So then they just start throwing massive banquets and feasts. They offer what are treats. Treating, like obviously the thing in the Pickwick Papers is a treat.
当地决定的，它们可以在不同的时间发生，通常它们可以在不同的日子发生。所以这是一个大型提名会议。如果候选人超过两名，那么基本上每个人都会说，是的，我们要进行选举。然后他们就开始举办大型宴会和盛宴。他们提供所谓的“款待”。款待，就像《匹克威克外传》里的事情显然是一种款待。
And treating is probably the central element of an election campaign. It's basically big open air street parties, sausage rolls, beer, pies. This would be illegal now. I haven't really thought that through. The idea of going to a treat organised by Keir Starmer would fill me with such gloom, Tom. I don't know. I'd go to them all. Would you? Spit roasting a hog.
而款待可能是选举活动的核心要素。这基本上是大型露天街头派对、香肠卷、啤酒、馅饼。这在现在是非法的。我还没真正想过这个问题。去参加基尔·斯塔默组织的款待的想法会让我感到如此沮丧，汤姆。我不知道。我会参加所有的。你会吗？烤全猪。
They wouldn't be, though, would they? Come on. The Labour Party aren't going to be spit roasting a hog. Rolling out barrels of beer. That's reform. That's Farage's treat. Yeah. Well, I think that might help him sweep to power. I mean, that's basically him posing with his beer, which he always does.
他们不会那样做，对吧？得了吧。工党不会去烤全猪。滚出啤酒桶。那是改革党。那是法拉奇的款待。是的。嗯，我想这可能有助于他横扫权力。我的意思是，这基本上就是他拿着啤酒摆姿势，他总是这样做。
Yeah. That's in the tradition, isn't it? That's a kind of vestige in a weird way of this. And like Ed Davey going on his log flumes and falling off paddle boards. Again, the Liberal Democrat leader. Well, we'll be coming to that. But I just wonder whether this whole thing of you have a massive street party for people, I mean, presumably that can't be legal anymore.
是的。这在传统中，不是吗？这在某种程度上是一种遗迹。就像埃德·戴维去玩原木滑道，从桨板上掉下来。同样是自由民主党领袖。嗯，我们稍后会谈到这一点。但我只是想知道，你为人们举办大型街头派对的整件事，我的意思是，大概那不再合法了。
People would do it. It would probably be considered bribery. I don't think you're allowed to give anything. There were various bribery acts to try and get around all this. But what they would do is, for example, the parties would sell goods. So they'd say, well, we're not bribing anybody. We're actually selling things. But they'd sell them at massive discounts
人们会这样做。这可能会被视为贿赂。我不认为你被允许给予任何东西。有各种贿赂法案试图绕过所有这些。但他们会做的是，例如，政党会出售商品。所以他们会说，嗯，我们没有贿赂任何人。我们实际上是在卖东西。但他们会以巨大的折扣出售它们
so that you would be getting stuff like a quarter of the price. So it kind of is bribery, but disguised. And they would go around. They'd give everybody in the town ribbons and cockades and all different colors. There's no set colors. You would choose colors yourself, really. In the American Revolutionary period,
这样你就能以四分之一的价格买到东西。所以这有点像贿赂，但经过了伪装。他们会到处走。他们会给镇上的每个人丝带和帽徽，各种不同的颜色。没有固定的颜色。你真的会自己选择颜色。在美国革命时期，
the colors associated with the American Revolution, I read a blue and buff. So Charles James Fox, who's very keen on the American Revolution, he wears blue and buff, but his opponent, Sir Cecil Ray, wears green instead. So it's just totally random. The election starts when you open the polls. So what this means is there's a big sort of hustings. So it's big and it's kind of open air. Often the sheriff or the mayor or some local grandee reads the writ of election to a big crowd. And then the way it works, let's say you want to vote, Tom, you're in Wiltshire. Yeah. And I've banged my pot or whatever it is you do. Yes, exactly. You've walloped your pot and you're surrounded by your faggot voters.
与美国革命相关的颜色，我读到是蓝色和浅黄色。所以查尔斯·詹姆斯·福克斯，他非常热衷于美国革命，他穿蓝色和浅黄色，但他的对手塞西尔·雷爵士却穿绿色。所以这完全是随机的。选举在投票开始时开始。所以这意味着有一个大型的竞选集会。所以它很大，而且是露天的。通常警长或市长或某个当地显贵向一大群人宣读选举令状。然后运作方式是，假设你想投票，汤姆，你在威尔特郡。是的。而我敲了我的锅或者无论你做什么。是的，完全正确。你敲了你的锅，你被你的柴火选民包围了。
So the way it works is you would have to go and you'd have to give your vote orally for everyone to hear. Oh, so everyone would know who I'd voted for. Yeah, and you have two votes, except if you're in London where you have four votes or if you're in Abingdon where you have one for reasons that are unclear. Right, unclear.
所以运作方式是，你必须去，你必须口头投票，让每个人都能听到。哦，所以每个人都会知道我投给了谁。是的，你有两张选票，除非你在伦敦，你有四张选票，或者在阿宾登，你有一张选票，原因不清楚。对，不清楚。
So you have your two votes. Now, there were tickets. So people would say, the Whig men are Dalrymple and Young Smith or whatever. Yeah. And you could choose to go down the Whig ticket, or you could split your vote, or you could say only one of those men is suitable to be voted for. So I will only use one vote. The other man is not worth my while.
所以你有两张选票。现在，有票。所以人们会说，辉格党人是达尔林普尔和杨·史密斯之类的。是的。你可以选择走辉格党路线，或者你可以拆分你的选票，或者你可以说只有其中一个人适合被投票。所以我只会用一张选票。另一个人不值得我花时间。
So I guess that explains the whole bribery thing, because if everyone knows who you're voting for, then you can't just go around and, you know. No, not at all. Now, obviously the crowd are hooting and roaring and throwing things and stuff. Throwing dead cats. Right. There's quite a lot of dead cat action, isn't there, at this point? If you like dead cats, this is the podcast for you. So you would come up in what was called a tally. And a tally is maybe 10 or 20 people.
所以我猜这就解释了整个贿赂的事情，因为如果每个人都知道你在投给谁，那么你就不能只是到处走走，你知道。不，完全不能。现在，显然人群在嘘声、咆哮、扔东西之类的。扔死猫。对。此时此刻有很多死猫动作，不是吗？如果你喜欢死猫，这就是适合你的播客。所以你会以所谓的“计票组”形式出现。而计票组可能是10或20个人。
There would be a tally captain who would wear the colours of your candidate. So you'd say, I'm a wig man. And you'd get together with the wig tally. There'd be a tally captain. And he would lead you. He might have a banner. He might have a band. And you'd all go together, you know, as a group for safety, basically.
会有一个计票组长，他会穿上你候选人的颜色。所以你会说，我是辉格党人。你会和辉格党计票组聚在一起。会有一个计票组长。他会带领你。他可能有一面旗帜。他可能有一个乐队。你们会一起走，你知道，为了安全，基本上。
Yeah. So that's the paper sing, the procession as a group for safety, basically. Yeah. So that's the pickwick papers thing, the procession. They're all bunched together. Exactly. And that's why they have to sort the babies. Now, you might think this is a tremendous day. You'd be wrong.
是的。所以这就是《匹克威克外传》的事情，游行队伍。他们都挤在一起。完全正确。这就是为什么他们必须整理婴儿。现在，你可能认为这是极其美好的一天。你错了。
It's not a tremendous day. It could be a tremendous month that this goes on for. Great. So in some places where there are a lot of voters, this would just go on and on and on. And they would almost sort of drag it out. In fact, dragging it out so far that in 1696, Parliament had to pass a law to say, you've got to get this done and dusted in 40 days. And who's in control of it? The local sheriff or mayor or whatever, the local authorities.
这不是极其美好的一天。这可能是持续一个月的极其美好的一天。太棒了。所以有些选民很多的地方，这会没完没了地进行下去。他们几乎会拖延它。事实上，拖延得太久了，以至于在1696年，议会不得不通过一项法律说，你必须在40天内完成并结束它。谁在控制它？当地警长或市长之类的，当地当局。
And so they supposedly are neutral, but they're not. Yeah, but obviously they're not neutral often, as we will see. So you've gone and you've done your voting. At the end of the day, the candidates come out and address the crowd. You might think sensible to do it at the beginning, but no, do it at the end. They do it at the end of the day. They say, thanks for everyone who voted for me. The rest of you, there's always tomorrow. And then they would lead a procession, the rival candidates, with all their bands and all their banners to a tavern. So they'd generally be staying in a tavern in the town and each would have a different tavern as their headquarters. And then they'd go into the
所以他们理应是中立的，但他们不是。是的，但显然他们通常不是中立的，正如我们将看到的。所以你已经去投票了。在一天结束时，候选人出来向人群发表讲话。你可能认为在开始时这样做很明智，但没有，在一天结束时做。他们在一天结束时这样做。他们说，感谢所有投票给我的人。剩下的人，总有明天。然后他们会带领游行队伍，竞争对手，带着他们所有的乐队和旗帜去一家酒馆。所以他们通常会住在镇上的一家酒馆里，每个人都会有不同的酒馆作为总部。然后他们会走进
tavern, drink would be had, then they'd come out and they'd address the crowd again from a window. There'd be lots of cheering and bants. And presumably by this point, they're quite inebriated. Yeah, exactly so. Which always improves an election address. So on the last day of the election, when everybody's voted, or when we've got to the 40 days, the votes, they're all recorded in a book and they're counted. And then the result is read out to this now gigantic crowd. And then, this is a strange detail, the winning candidates would be put on chairs and carried through the town. That's kind of fair enough. And there'd be great crowds following them.
酒馆，喝点酒，然后他们会出来，再次从窗户向人群发表讲话。会有很多欢呼和戏谑。大概到这个时候，他们已经相当醉了。是的，完全正确。这总是能改善选举演讲。所以在选举的最后一天，当每个人都投了票，或者当我们到了40天时，选票，它们都被记录在一本书里并被清点。然后结果被读给现在巨大的人群听。然后，这是一个奇怪的细节，获胜的候选人会被放在椅子上，抬着穿过城镇。这算公平。会有大批人群跟着他们。
Some shouting abuse, some saying brilliant. I mean, quite risky, I'd have thought, if there's dead cat throwing and you're on a chair. Of course. Of course. You've got to be gutsy to do this. And you've got disappointed voters. Right. So by now, everyone would be absolutely hammered.
有的喊着辱骂的话，有的说太棒了。我的意思是，如果有人扔死猫，而你坐在椅子上，我想这相当冒险。当然。当然。你必须有胆量才能这样做。而且你有失望的选民。对。所以到目前为止，每个人都会绝对喝醉了。
Yeah. So there's that as well. So there'd be lots of fighting and there'd be people falling over. And then at the end, the detail that I like, you'd be carried back to your tavern and then the crowd would ritually tear apart the chair. Presumably to hit each other with. I don't know what they... So the thing is, as you might expect from this description of how voting works, there is enormous scope for fighting and bad behaviour. Yeah.
是的。所以也有这种情况。所以会有很多打斗，会有很多人摔倒。然后在最后，我喜欢的细节是，你会被抬回你的酒馆，然后人群会仪式性地撕碎椅子。大概是为了用它们互相打。我不知道他们……所以事情是这样的，正如你从这种投票运作方式的描述中所预料的那样，打斗和不良行为的空间巨大。是的。
I mean, it's basically like the Euros, isn't it? Yeah. Loads of rival drunk fans. Totally. England football fans would be in heaven with this. They could be singing all their songs, throwing stuff. It's a rich carnivalesque tradition. That's exactly what it is.
我的意思是，这基本上就像欧洲杯，不是吗？是的。大量的竞争对手醉酒球迷。完全。英格兰足球迷会喜欢这个的。他们可以唱所有的歌，扔东西。这是一种丰富的嘉年华传统。这正是它的样子。
So there's loads of violence. There's loads of attacks on taverns. There's stones being hurled. There's people with flipping halberds. There's grenadiers. There's all this kind of stuff. Basically, lots of hijinks tom and i think what we could do in the second half we're a bit of a match of the day podcast aren't we so we'll go with the edited highlights i know you're gagging to hear all about the election of
所以有很多暴力。有很多对酒馆的袭击。有石头被投掷。有人拿着挥舞的戟。有掷弹兵。有所有这些东西。基本上，有很多恶作剧，汤姆，我认为我们在下半场可以做的是，我们有点像“今日比赛”播客，不是吗？所以我们将提供编辑后的亮点，我知道你急于听到关于1698年选举的一切，
1698 terrible scenes in coventry in 1705 shocking business with the liberals in cheltenham in 1865 so we'll go all the way through give you the absolutely the tipped up highlights and tom we'll do all that after the break. See you in a minute. I'm Marina Hyde. And I'm Richard Osman, and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment. It's your weekly fix of entertainment news, reviews, splash of showbiz gossip, and on our Q&A,
1705年考文垂的可怕场景，1865年切尔滕纳姆自由党人的令人震惊的事情，所以我们将全程回顾，给你绝对的精选亮点，汤姆，我们将在休息后做所有这些。一会儿见。我是玛丽娜·海德。我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《娱乐余温》。这是你每周的娱乐新闻、评论、一点演艺圈八卦，以及在我们的问答环节，
we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works. We have just launched our Members Club. If you want ad-free listening, bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. Welcome back to The Rest Is History. So let's start at the beginning of party politics. We're in the 1690s, the reign of William III. People are talking now about Whigs and Tories.
我们拉开娱乐的帷幕，告诉你它是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了我们的会员俱乐部。如果你想要无广告收听、额外剧集和抢先获得现场门票，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。那是 therestisentertainment.com。欢迎回到《历史余温》。所以让我们从政党政治的开始说起。我们在1690年代，威廉三世统治时期。人们现在在谈论辉格党和托利党。
So Whigs, gosh, how to explain Whigs. We often get asked this and it fills me with dread. Because it evolves, doesn't it? It does. The Whigs are kind of the Protestant succession, mercantile. They're back in the Glorious Revolution. They're back in the Glorious Revolution. Which has seen James II thrown out. So essentially suspending the natural laws of
所以辉格党，天哪，如何解释辉格党。我们经常被问到这个问题，这让我感到恐惧。因为它在演变，不是吗？确实。辉格党有点像新教继承，商业化。他们支持光荣革命。他们支持光荣革命。这导致詹姆斯二世被赶下台。所以基本上暂停了自然的
succession. Yes, because they love a Protestant above all. And they are softer on dissent, on non-conformism, on kind of low church religion, and they despise nothing more than a papist. And Tories, they have a slight Jacobite tinge to them. Yeah. So, I mean, even, you know, a century on, Dr. Johnson is a great Jacobite. King over the water, all that. The king over the water, yes. And a supporter of the established church. Yeah. And Tories say, oh, the Whigs are terrible, metropolitan, they're interested in Europe,
继承法。是的，因为他们最爱新教徒。而且他们对异议、非国教、低教会宗教更宽容，他们最鄙视的就是教皇信徒。而托利党，他们带有一点詹姆斯党色彩。是的。所以，我的意思是，即使是一个世纪后，约翰逊博士也是一个伟大的詹姆斯党。水上的国王，所有这些。水上的国王，是的。以及国教的支持者。是的。而托利党说，哦，辉格党很糟糕，大都市化，他们对欧洲感兴趣，
they are do-gooders, they're out of touch with the bottom, the common sense of old England. Yes. That's basically what a Tory says of a Whig. Whereas the Whigs say they're Tories, they're clapped out, red-faced old fools. I mean, the stereotype would be that you are a Tory and I am a Whig. It's not actually true, though, is it? I don't think. No, it's not true.
他们是好心人，他们与底层、老英格兰的常识脱节。是的。这基本上就是托利党对辉格党的评价。而辉格党说他们是托利党，他们是过气的、红脸的老傻瓜。我的意思是，刻板印象会是你是一个托利党，而我是辉格党。但这其实不是真的，对吧？我不认为。不，这不是真的。
But that would be people's stereotype, I guess. This is the personas, Tom, that we've confected for the podcast, isn't it? I don't want to let too much light in, but yeah. I mean, a Whig generally has the look of someone who eats too many vegetables. Yeah, absolutely. And a Tory has the look of someone who enjoys his beef. Yeah. So to that extent, that's the dynamic of the podcast. Right. Anyway, we've explained that in a very ham-fisted way, but that's appropriate under the circumstances. So I'm a Whig, you're a Tory. Just keep that vaguely in your head. So 1698, there's an election.
但这会是人们的刻板印象，我猜。这就是我们为播客编造的角色，汤姆，不是吗？我不想让太多的光照进来，但是的。我的意思是，辉格党通常看起来像那种吃太多蔬菜的人。是的，完全正确。而托利党看起来像那种喜欢吃牛肉的人。是的。所以在这个程度上，这就是播客的动态。对。无论如何，我们以一种非常笨拙的方式解释了这一点，但这在当时的情况下是合适的。所以我是一个辉格党，你是托利党。只要把这一点模糊地记在脑子里。所以1698年，有一场选举。
Basically, the Whigs are in and they're defending their position against the Tories who are out. And out of 269 seats, 104 of them are contested. And we'll just look at one, which is Westminster. Westminster had a very big electorate. It had about 15,000 to 20,000 people. That's the biggest of the lot, isn't it? Yeah. And because it's the fulcrum of power, it's got parliament in it. Yes. That always adds an extra foesaw. So it's got parliament in it. It's very urban. And because it's got parliament in it yes that always adds an extra foesaw so it's got parliament in it it's very urban and because it's so big you can't manage it through bribery and patronage so it's always contested now traditionally what would happen is the rival groups of political
基本上，辉格党人掌权，他们正在捍卫自己的地位，对抗在野的托利党人。在269个席位中，有104个席位存在竞争。我们只看其中一个，那就是威斯敏斯特。威斯敏斯特的选民人数非常多，大约有1.5万到2万人。那是所有选区中最大的，不是吗？是的。而且因为它是权力的支点，议会就在那里。是的。这总是增加了一种额外的……所以它里面有议会。它非常城市化。而且因为它里面有议会，是的，这总是增加了一种额外的……所以它里面有议会，它非常城市化，而且因为它太大了，你无法通过贿赂和恩惠来控制它，所以它总是存在竞争。现在，传统上，敌对的政治团体
enthusiasts would assemble on what was called tuttle fields or tot hill fields this is a big open patch of ground and they would just have a massive fight that's how it would work i would just think that would be brilliant i mean you could just put it on sky sports yeah exactly stream it live so you have two candidates who are wigs in this election charles montague and james vernon and opposing them of course as a man man with the ultimate kind of Tory stroke country name, which is Sir Henry Dutton Colt's baronet. No nonsense. Can I just ask, the two Whigs, they're not competing against each other. They're kind of running on a joint ticket, are they?
狂热分子会聚集在所谓的塔特尔广场或托特希尔广场，这是一块很大的开阔地，他们会进行一场大规模的斗殴，这就是当时的情况。我只是觉得那会很精彩，我的意思是你可以把它放在天空体育上，是的，完全可以直播。所以这次选举中有两名辉格党候选人，查尔斯·蒙塔古和詹姆斯·弗农，当然，反对他们的是一个拥有终极托利党或乡村名字的人，那就是亨利·达顿·科尔特男爵。非常干脆。我能问一下吗，那两个辉格党人，他们不是在互相竞争吗？他们是以联合候选人的身份参选，是吗？
Yeah. Remember, every seat has two MPs. Yeah. So they basically want to squeeze out Sir Henry Dutton Colt baronet. Is he the only Tory? Yes, he's the only guy. I think he's the only Tory running in that election. And in fact, their party political allegiances are so fluid.
是的。记住，每个席位有两名议员。是的。所以他们基本上是想挤走亨利·达顿·科尔特男爵。他是唯一的托利党人吗？是的，他是唯一的人。我想他是那次选举中唯一参选的托利党人。事实上，他们的政党政治忠诚度非常不稳定。
So like a couple of years later, he's a Whig or something. It's just bonkers. Yeah. He arrives with all his guys, some of whom are like equipped with like a little knife or a cudgel or something. Well, I mean, the Tory, you know, they're hunting, shooting, fishing. Yeah, absolutely. But he's behind the times.
所以几年后，他成了辉格党人什么的。这简直太疯狂了。是的。他带着他的人马来了，其中一些人配备了小刀或棍棒之类的东西。嗯，我的意思是，托利党人，你知道，他们打猎、射击、钓鱼。是的，绝对是。但他已经过时了。
Vernon and Montague are much more modern because they arrive with, they're hunting, shooting, fishing. Yeah, absolutely. But he's behind the times. Vernon and Montague are much more modern because they arrive with, and I quote, a troop of several thousand horsemen. And they charge Sir Henry Desson Colt's men and drive them. And I quote, this is Vernon himself said, the Whig, you know, not so much a do-gooder. He said, my men ran down Colt's men at a strange rate
弗农和蒙塔古要现代得多，因为他们带着……他们打猎、射击、钓鱼。是的，绝对是。但他已经过时了。弗农和蒙塔古要现代得多，因为他们带着，引用一下，“一支数千人的骑兵队”。他们冲向亨利·达顿·科尔特的人马并驱赶他们。我引用一下，这是弗农自己说的，那个辉格党人，你知道，不是什么大善人。他说：“我的人以惊人的速度冲垮了科尔特的人。”
and cuddled them into ditches full of water. And he was unrepentant about this, James Vernon. He said, Colt's supporters are, and I quote, the very scum of the town, victualers, porters, and chairmen. So men who basically carry on a sedan chair. Yeah, well, fair enough. So it's very like people throwing milk at... No, it's a farage.
并把他们赶进了装满水的沟渠里。詹姆斯·弗农对此毫无悔意。他说，科尔特的支持者是，我引用一下，“城里的渣滓，小贩、搬运工和轿夫。”也就是那些基本上抬轿子的人。是的，好吧，有道理。所以这很像人们向……扔牛奶。不，这是一场骚乱。
Well, actually, so after this, Henry Dustin Colt, well, fair enough. So it's very like people throwing milk at... No, it's a farage. Well, actually, so after this, Sir Henry Dustin Colt Baronet, he lost. He finished 600 votes behind James Vernon and 800 votes behind Charles Montagu. And he petitioned Parliament to have the result cancelled. He said they had gone too far. One of his men had died from wounds inflicted during a cavalry charge.
嗯，实际上，在这之后，亨利·达顿·科尔特，好吧，有道理。所以这很像人们向……扔牛奶。不，这是一场骚乱。嗯，实际上，在这之后，亨利·达顿·科尔特男爵，他输了。他比詹姆斯·弗农少了600票，比查尔斯·蒙塔古少了800票。他向议会请愿要求取消结果。他说他们做得太过分了。他的一名手下在骑兵冲锋中受了伤，最终死亡。
He said that Vernon and Montagu had broken the rules, the accepted rules, by employing off-duty grenadiers against his men, and that he himself had been threatened with pistols. I love it that there are rules that say you can't employ off-duty grenadiers. Yeah. Well, Parliament said, no, there's no such rule. This is all completely acceptable for a parliamentary campaign. So his petition was thrown out. But it actually wasn't the best thing that happened in 1698 because there are even more exciting scenes in Norfolk.
他说弗农和蒙塔古打破了规则，即公认的规则，雇佣了休假的掷弹兵来对付他的人，而且他自己还受到了手枪的威胁。我喜欢这种规定，说你不能雇佣休假的掷弹兵。是的。嗯，议会说，不，没有这样的规定。这对议会竞选来说完全是可以接受的。所以他的请愿被驳回了。但这实际上并不是1698年发生的最棒的事情，因为诺福克有更令人兴奋的场面。
So here, one of the MPs is a man called Sir Henry Hobart, another baronet. He's a Whig. He was knighted by Charles II when he was 13, very impressively. But he loses his seat in 1698 to two Tories because two Tories returned from Norfolk. And Sir Henry Hobart is absolutely furious at this. And he says, I know who's to blame.
所以在这里，其中一位议员是一个叫亨利·霍巴特爵士的人，也是一位男爵。他是个辉格党人。他在13岁时被查理二世封为爵士，非常令人印象深刻。但在1698年，他输给了两名托利党人，因为两名托利党人在诺福克当选了。亨利·霍巴特爵士对此感到非常愤怒。他说，我知道是谁的错。
It's basically a guy who lives down the road, another landowner, called Oliver Leneve. He's a dyed-in-the-wool Tory squire. He spends all his time hunting and fishing. And Hobart is convinced that Leneve has been spreading rumors that he's a coward, specifically that he behaved in a cowardly manner at the Battle of the Boyne. And he says, this is absolutely disgrace. This is the only reason I lost this seat is because this Leneve has been spreading these rumors.
基本上是一个住在路那头的家伙，另一个地主，叫奥利弗·勒内夫。他是一个彻头彻尾的托利党乡绅。他把所有时间都花在打猎和钓鱼上。霍巴特确信勒内夫一直在散布谣言说他是个懦夫，特别是在博因河战役中表现得像个懦夫。他说，这绝对是耻辱。我失去这个席位的唯一原因就是这个勒内夫一直在散布这些谣言。
Leneve says, I've never told anybody these things about you. But Hobart won't accept it and challenges him to a duel because he's so upset at losing his seat. And of thinking that people are calling him a coward. So you challenge someone to a duel to prove your manhood. Yeah, your manhood. So for some obscure reason, they fight on a heath midway between their two houses, but with no seconds. I read that there was a servant girl hiding in the bush who was the only person to observe this.
勒内夫说，我从来没跟任何人说过关于你的这些事。但霍巴特不接受，并向他发起决斗，因为他对自己失去席位感到非常沮丧。而且认为人们在叫他懦夫。所以你向某人发起决斗来证明你的男子气概。是的，你的男子气概。所以出于某种模糊的原因，他们在两家房子中间的荒地上决斗，但没有助手。我读到有一个女仆躲在灌木丛里，她是唯一观察到这一幕的人。
I don't know why she was hiding in the bush, but anyway. Hobart is a much more accomplished swordsman. So he clearly thinks easy win. And he's so fast, he strikes first. But his sword gets tangled in Leneve's coat. And Leneve, very unsentimentally, immediately just runs him through in the stomach. And Hobart dies. So he's lost his seat and his life.
我不知道她为什么要躲在灌木丛里，但总之。霍巴特是一位更有造诣的剑客。所以他显然认为这是一场轻松的胜利。他出剑很快，先发制人。但他的剑缠在了勒内夫的外套上。勒内夫非常冷酷地立即刺穿了他的胃。霍巴特死了。所以他不仅失去了席位，还失去了生命。
And Leneve fled to Holland. And then he returned after two years. He was acquitted. The jury acquitted him because they said he's a tremendous fellow. I think that reflects well on the jury. Do you know that's the last duel in Norfolk history, Tom? And it's said, it is said, that if you visit the Heath, then sometimes at night you can hear ghostly swords clashing in the darkness.
勒内夫逃到了荷兰。两年后他回来了。他被判无罪。陪审团判他无罪，因为他们说他是个了不起的家伙。我认为这反映了陪审团的良好素质。你知道那是诺福克历史上最后一场决斗吗，汤姆？据说，如果你去那片荒地，有时在晚上你能听到黑暗中幽灵般的剑击声。
And perhaps see the servant girl hiding in a bush. Perhaps you can. So that's 1698. Would you like to hear about 1705? Yeah, I'd love to. So 1705, the sort of party politics is, it's only seven years on, but it's becoming a tiny bit more recognisable. It's becoming a little bit more predictable. It's all about kind of, the Tories say the Church of England is in danger from radicals and dissenters. The Whigs say, oh, the Tories are a bunch of Catholics. Terrible scenes.
也许还能看到躲在灌木丛里的女仆。也许你能。所以那是1698年。你想听听1705年的事吗？是的，我很想听。所以1705年，那种政党政治，虽然才过了七年，但已经变得稍微容易辨认了一点。它变得稍微更容易预测了。这完全是关于……托利党人说英国国教正受到激进分子和异见者的威胁。辉格党人说，哦，托利党人是一群天主教徒。可怕的场面。
So at this point, it's not about tax. Well, it's partly about the War of the Spanish Succession, raising taxes for the war, all of that kind of thing. Oh, so it is still about tax. Yeah, so tax is always kind of lurking there. Tax and religion. Tax and culture wars. It's culture wars and tax.
所以此时，这与税收无关。嗯，这部分与西班牙王位继承战争有关，为战争增加税收，所有这些事情。哦，所以还是关于税收。是的，所以税收总是潜伏在那里。税收和宗教。税收和文化战争。这是文化战争和税收。
So when people say, oh, these terrible culture wars, what a terrible distraction from real things. That's tosh and rubbish. Culture wars have always been at the absolute centre. So that kind of high church, low church thing, it absolutely feeds into the culture wars today. Totally it does. Yeah, absolutely. It's enduring. So why not? Let's go to Coventry. Yeah, I love Coventry. Coventry is a big and bustling place in 1705. It's a big trading city and it's an absolute
所以当人们说，哦，这些可怕的文化战争，真是对现实问题的可怕干扰。那是胡说八道。文化战争一直处于绝对中心。所以那种高教会、低教会的东西，它绝对助长了今天的文化战争。完全是这样。是的，绝对是。它是持久的。所以为什么不呢？让我们去考文垂。是的，我喜欢考文垂。考文垂在1705年是一个繁忙的大地方。它是一个巨大的贸易城市，绝对是
hotbed of religious dissent. So the politics of the town is dominated by Presbyterians, not Church of England. And as a result of that, it is a real Whig stronghold. So not a place for a Tory? Not a place for a Tory, or so you would think. Because in the run-up to this election, which is that summer, there are weeks and weeks of clashes between rival Whig and Tory mobs. And I think because they are so outgunned in the town, the Tories just think, you know, we've got to do something special here. So there's going to be a three-day election in Coventry.
宗教异见的温床。所以这个城镇的政治由长老会主导，而不是英国国教。因此，它是一个真正的辉格党据点。所以不是托利党人的地方？不是托利党人的地方，或者你是这么认为的。因为在那年夏天选举前夕，辉格党和托利党暴徒之间发生了持续数周的冲突。而且我认为因为他们在城里火力不足，托利党人只是想，你知道，我们必须在这里做点特别的事情。所以考文垂将举行一场为期三天的选举。
And the night before it kicks off, hundreds of Tory supporters pour into the town armed with howlbirds. That's very retro. Very retro, exactly. Well, the Tories are quite retro, aren't they, I suppose? Yeah. Merry England, all that stuff. They march into the town and they seize the Guildhall.
在选举开始的前一天晚上，数百名托利党支持者带着长戟涌入城中。这非常复古。非常复古，没错。嗯，托利党人相当复古，不是吗，我想？是的。快乐的英格兰，所有那些东西。他们开进城里，占领了市政厅。
There's about 700 of them. And because they control the Guildhall, they've basically seized it from the authorities. So they can now run the election. They can run the election, which they do. So as I read, those favouring the Tory candidates were admitted unhindered, but they were, and I quote, ready to eat anybody offering themselves for the wigs. So basically, all the people who say their Tory vote is fine. And if you're a wig, then you will be, this is a very strange thing.
大约有700人。因为他们控制了市政厅，他们基本上从当局手中夺取了它。所以他们现在可以操纵选举了。他们可以操纵选举，他们也确实这么做了。正如我所读到的，那些支持托利党候选人的人被毫无阻碍地放行，但他们，我引用一下，“准备吃掉任何为辉格党提供自己的人。”所以基本上，所有说他们投托利党票的人都没事。如果你是辉格党人，那么你将会，这是一件非常奇怪的事情。
You will be, quote, horsed, viz, carried on men's shoulders upon cowl staff and dragged upon the ground. So I've discovered what that means. That means you'd be sort of tied to a stick, like a big stick, and you'd be carried between two men. Like a kind of captured animal. Yeah, like a trust animal. And then they'd drag you on the ground. That's very Tory, isn't it? Hunters would do that. Exactly. Now, this was seen as going too far, because actually two Tory candidates unsurprisingly won. But there was a massive kind of case that comes before Parliament. And in 1707, two years later, the election was declared void and the Whigs win. So there are some standards.
你将会，引用，“被骑马”，即被扛在男人的肩膀上，用长棍抬着，并在地上拖行。所以我发现了那是什么意思。这意味着你会被绑在一根棍子上，像一根大棍子，你会由两个人抬着。像一种被捕获的动物。是的，像一只被捆绑的动物。然后他们会把你拖在地上。那非常托利党，不是吗？猎人会那样做。没错。现在，这被视为做得太过分了，因为实际上两名托利党候选人不出所料地赢了。但议会面前出现了一个巨大的案件。1707年，两年后，选举被宣布无效，辉格党赢了。所以还是有一些标准的。
A duel is fine. Grenadiers and cavalry charges are fine. The use of halberds. Halberds is not. Halberds is absolutely not fine. Which I suppose just proves the darkest Tory suspicions that England's going to the dogs. Totally. Yeah.
决斗是可以的。掷弹兵和骑兵冲锋是可以的。使用长戟。长戟绝对是不行的。这我想只是证明了托利党最黑暗的怀疑，即英格兰正在走向毁灭。完全是。是的。
And that the good old traditions are being phased out by humorless prigs. Yeah. Nanny state prigs. Nanny state prigs. That's exactly what it is. So now we could go through the whole 18th century like this and we'd be here till, you know, the crack of doom. Let's fast forward a bit to the 19th century.
而且那些美好的旧传统正在被毫无幽默感的伪君子所淘汰。是的。保姆国家的伪君子。保姆国家的伪君子。这正是它的本质。所以现在我们可以像这样经历整个18世纪，我们会一直在这里，直到，你知道，世界末日。让我们快进到19世纪。
So there's still a fair bit of violence, but it's slightly less mob and halberd and a bit more throwing dogs and bants, I think is fair to say, Tom. So this is the Pitwick Papers era? This is the Pitwick Papers era. So basically, whenever you turned out as an MP, if it was a contested election, people would throw at you stinking fish, dead dogs, cats and rats, a candidate for Sussex in 1820,
所以仍然有相当多的暴力，但稍微少了一些暴徒和长戟，多了一些扔狗和……我想说这是公平的，汤姆。所以这是《匹克威克外传》时代？这是《匹克威克外传》时代。所以基本上，无论你什么时候作为议员出现，如果这是一场竞争激烈的选举，人们会向你扔臭鱼、死狗、猫和老鼠，1820年苏塞克斯的一名候选人，
bombarded with the rotten eggs and dead cats of Chichester. There's tons of dead cats in kind of Regency England, early Victorian England. So what would you rather have thrown at you, a dead cat or rotten eggs? I think I'd take the egg. I'm just imagining the feel of a dead cat on my face as it impacted.
被奇切斯特的臭鸡蛋和死猫轰炸。摄政时期的英格兰，维多利亚时代早期，到处都是死猫。所以你宁愿被扔什么，死猫还是臭鸡蛋？我想我会选鸡蛋。我只是在想象死猫撞击我脸上的感觉。
I think that's horrible. It actually gives me the chills to think of it, Tom. This is the kind of analysis you don't get on other podcasts. No way, no way. All those politics shows have been riding high during the election campaign. But they're not debating the issues that matter. No. No.
我觉得那太可怕了。想到它甚至让我不寒而栗，汤姆。这就是你在其他播客中得不到的那种分析。没门，没门。所有那些政治节目在竞选期间都高高在上。但他们没有讨论重要的问题。不。不。
Where's the dead dogs? Where's the cats? Yeah. Where's the Bristol election of 1830? Where indeed, Dominic? Tell us about the Bristol election of 1830. So this is Hilary Burlough again. And Bristol, slave trade, obviously a big issue.
死狗在哪里？猫在哪里？是的。1830年的布里斯托尔选举在哪里？确实如此，多米尼克？告诉我们1830年的布里斯托尔选举。所以这又是希拉里·伯洛。布里斯托尔，奴隶贸易，显然是一个大问题。
And abolitionism, a huge issue. But here you get some excellent fighting between rival Whigs. So within the Whigs themselves, if there's lots of people competing and the party organisation is quite weak, you can have rival candidates from the same party, from the same movement, for the same seats, effectively. So like the Tories today, Dominic. Like the Tories today. Very good. Very good. So here we've got two guys, two Whigs fighting for one slot. They're Edward Prothero and James Bailey. Edward Prothero is a massive do-gooder, Tom. He supports votes for Catholics and he supports the abolition of slavery. Now, James Bailey is
废奴主义，一个巨大的问题。但在这里，你可以在敌对的辉格党人之间看到一些精彩的战斗。所以在辉格党内部，如果有很多竞争者，而且政党组织相当薄弱，你实际上可以有来自同一个政党、同一个运动的竞争候选人，争夺同一个席位。所以就像今天的托利党人，多米尼克。就像今天的托利党人。非常好。非常好。所以这里我们有两个家伙，两个辉格党人争夺一个名额。他们是爱德华·普罗瑟罗和詹姆斯·贝利。爱德华·普罗瑟罗是一个大善人，汤姆。他支持天主教徒投票，他支持废除奴隶制。现在，詹姆斯·贝利是
also a Whig, so a bit of a do-gooder, but he's more moderate. And actually, his opponents say of him, oh, he's just pretending to hate slavery. So by moderate, he's not in favor of abolishing the slave trade, in other words. No, he is, but more gradually. He's a gradualist. He's Keir Starmer to Prothero's Diane Abbott, I suppose it's fair to say. And his opponents say of him, he's just a lackey of the West India interests. Actually, now, confusingly, this is very Labour Party. Bailey, the moderate, says of Prothero, he pretends to abhor slavery to pick
也是一个辉格党人，所以有点像个大善人，但他更温和。实际上，他的对手说他，哦，他只是假装讨厌奴隶制。所以所谓的温和，换句话说，他并不赞成废除奴隶贸易。不，他赞成，但更循序渐进。他是个渐进主义者。他是基尔·斯塔默对普罗瑟罗的黛安·阿博特，我想说这是公平的。他的对手说他，他只是西印度群岛利益的走狗。实际上，现在，令人困惑的是，这非常工党。贝利，那个温和派，说普罗瑟罗，他假装憎恶奴隶制来掏
the pockets of Quakers and other enthusiasts. And he also says, Prothero and all these Quakers, these sort of Whig momentum, they've actually secretly invested in a Brazilian gold mine that depends on slaves. So they are absolute latte sipping yeah this is all very familiar guardian reading hypocrites it's very like the debate about bailey gifford it is totally it is all the writers who uh oppose bailey gifford who have their books on amazon yeah that's an investment company that was sponsoring book festivals that was basically driven out of the world was sponsoring book festivals that was basically driven out of the world were sponsoring book festivals by agitated lefty writers novelists exactly so these two guys they had this massive violence between their supporters when bailey the the gradualist enters bristol he has his procession into bristol there's a huge group of men and boys on horseback and i quote in a state
贵格会教徒和其他狂热分子的口袋。他还说，普罗瑟罗和所有这些贵格会教徒，这些辉格党动力，他们实际上秘密投资了一个依赖奴隶的巴西金矿。所以他们是绝对的拿铁咖啡……是的，这非常熟悉，读《卫报》的伪君子。这很像关于贝利·吉福德的辩论，完全是，所有反对贝利·吉福德的作家，他们的书都在亚马逊上，是的，那是一家赞助图书节的投资公司，基本上被激进的左翼作家、小说家赶出了世界。没错，所以这两个家伙，他们的支持者之间发生了巨大的暴力冲突，当贝利，那个渐进主义者进入布里斯托尔时，他有他的游行队伍进入布里斯托尔，有一大群骑马的男人和男孩，我引用，“处于
of intoxication many of them armed with bludgeons who attack his procession. So it's not all kind of organic shoes and tofu. No. This is the hard edge. I mean, no halberds, but the next best thing. So he comes out of his pub, which is the Rummer, to address the crowd.
醉酒状态，其中许多人带着棍棒”，他们袭击了他的游行队伍。所以这并不全是那种有机的鞋子和豆腐。不。这是硬边。我的意思是，没有长戟，但这是次好的东西。所以他从他的酒吧，也就是“拉默”酒吧出来，向人群发表讲话。
That's a great name for a pub. People hiss him. They charge his supporters. And in revenge, his supporters, and I quote, sailors and ships, carpenters in a dreadful state of infuriation, intoxication, also armed with bludgeons, they attack the other bloke's pub. There's massive fighting. And then 27 people had to be taken to the infirmary.
那是个很棒的酒吧名字。人们对他发出嘘声。他们冲向他的支持者。作为报复，他的支持者，我引用，“水手和船只，木匠处于一种可怕的愤怒、醉酒状态，也带着棍棒”，他们袭击了另一个家伙的酒吧。发生了大规模的战斗。然后27人不得不被送往医院。
The first day of polling, a Prothero, the abolitionist, he comes out of his pub to address the crowd. There's a hail of missiles. Somebody hits him on the head with a ladder. It's an oak ladder, I read. An oak ladder. An oak ladder. So it's like a ship's ladder, I presume.
投票的第一天，普罗瑟罗，那个废奴主义者，他从他的酒吧出来向人群发表讲话。一阵导弹雨。有人用梯子打中了他的头。我读到是一把橡木梯子。一把橡木梯子。一把橡木梯子。所以我想那就像船上的梯子。
The oak ladder of England. And I'm assuming this is something to do with, I mean, don't forget, there'd be a lot of people in those crowds who would be in favour of slavery because they basically think it's their livelihood, who are sporting the West India interest. So I'm wondering whether it's a ship's ladder and there's some sort of symbolism there that they've done it deliberately. Yeah, it could be. So anyway, Prothero lost by 500 votes. So that's the more radical abolitionist and the moderate one. But a year later, there was another election in 1831. The two guys who'd fought so bitterly
英格兰的橡木梯子。我假设这与……我的意思是，别忘了，那些人群中会有很多人赞成奴隶制，因为他们基本上认为这是他们的生计，他们支持西印度群岛的利益。所以我很好奇这是否是一把船梯，并且他们故意这样做有什么象征意义。是的，可能是。所以无论如何，普罗瑟罗输了500票。所以那是更激进的废奴主义者和温和派。但一年后，1831年又举行了一次选举。那两个斗争得如此激烈的家伙
were the only candidates and stood unopposed and there was no contest, no fighting, fighting nothing it's like they'd made up or something or done a deal yeah i mean that's the strange thing about it is that it's almost unknowable i guess it all seems so random and disorganized i mean there must be people who are sort of pulling the strings in some way like issuing oak ladders and dead cats but we don't really get much of a sense of them until later on. So let's move into the Victorian period. Obviously, the big story here is the expansion of the franchise. So you mentioned the Great Reform Act. Thanks to the Great Reform Act of 1832, about 650,000 people can vote. There's another Reform Act in 1867 that takes it to 2 million, and then in 1884 to about 6 million voters. That's still no women and a bare majority of men. So about 60% of men in Britain can vote and 40% can't because they don't have enough property.
是唯一的候选人，并且没有对手，没有竞争，没有战斗，什么都没有，就像他们和解了或者达成了协议。是的，我的意思是，这件奇怪的事情是，它几乎是不可知的，我想这一切看起来如此随机和混乱。我的意思是，一定有人在某种程度上操纵着，比如发放橡木梯子和死猫，但直到后来我们才真正感觉到他们。所以让我们进入维多利亚时代。显然，这里的大故事是选举权的扩大。所以你提到了《大改革法案》。多亏了1832年的《大改革法案》，大约65万人可以投票。1867年还有另一项《改革法案》，将其增加到200万，然后在1884年增加到大约600万选民。那仍然没有女性，而且男性只有勉强多数。所以英国大约60%的男性可以投票，40%不能，因为他们没有足够的财产。
Now, the other big thing, in 1872, there was a thing called the Ballot Act, which brought in secret ballots. And so that's the whole thing. You go behind the curtain. Nobody knows what you're voting. I'd always thought of that as a pretty fundamental principle of British democracy. I'm amazed it was so late being brought in. Yeah. And I think you and I can say this, Tom, obviously they wouldn't on these politics podcasts. That's the moment where it all went wrong for Britain, isn't it? I mean, the 1870s is probably also the point where the United States and Germany start to catch up with us economically. And I think that's no coincidence. Terrible times.
现在，另一件大事，1872年，有一项名为《投票法案》的东西，引入了秘密投票。所以这就是全部。你走到幕后。没人知道你在投谁。我一直认为那是英国民主的一个相当基本的原则。我很惊讶它这么晚才被引入。是的。我想你和我可以这么说，汤姆，显然他们不会在这些政治播客上说。那是英国一切出错的时刻，不是吗？我的意思是，1870年代可能也是美国和德国开始在经济上赶上我们的时刻。我认为这并非巧合。可怕的时代。
Yeah. The moment people started voting out of shame, I think that's no coincidence. Terrible times. Yeah. The moment people started voting, you know, out of shame, I think that's the moment we lost our political soul. Yeah, but the anti-vote take would be that it's 1832 and the widening of the franchise. Abolition of rotten boroughs. Yeah, that actually they should have heeded the 15th century petition that said too many people are voting. That was where it was at. Yeah, bring back the pot banging. Yeah. So with the expansion of the franchise,
是的。人们开始因为羞耻而投票的那一刻，我认为这并非巧合。可怕的时代。是的。人们开始，你知道，因为羞耻而投票的那一刻，我认为那是我们失去政治灵魂的时刻。是的，但反投票的观点会是1832年和选举权的扩大。废除腐败选区。是的，实际上他们应该听从15世纪的请愿书，说投票的人太多了。那才是重点。是的，把敲锅带回来。是的。随着选举权的扩大，
and then it's on with secret ballots, and obviously with the strengthening of party organisations and a general sense of kind of Gladstonian rectitude, the violence starts to decline. But happily for us, it does not end. So I've got three fun examples of Victorian larks. So one comes from the spa town of Cheltenham, 1865. Which is very kind of prim and proper.
然后是秘密投票，显然随着政党组织的加强和一种格莱斯顿式的正直感，暴力开始减少。但令我们高兴的是，它并没有结束。所以我这里有三个维多利亚时代恶作剧的有趣例子。一个来自切尔滕纳姆的温泉小镇，1865年。这非常……文雅和得体。
Very prim and proper. Exactly. That's what makes this so incongruous. So in 1865, Lord Palmerston's liberals beat the Earl of Derby's conservatives. And it was generally seen as a very dull election, basically an election dominated by corruption. But this is the great shining exception. And this is from a brilliant project done at Durham University called the Electoral Violence Project, which is all about Victorian electoral violence. It records 3,000 incidents
非常文雅和得体。没错。这就是让它如此不协调的原因。所以1865年，帕默斯顿勋爵的自由党击败了德比伯爵的保守党。这通常被视为一场非常沉闷的选举，基本上是一场被腐败主导的选举。但这却是伟大的闪亮例外。这是来自杜伦大学一个名为“选举暴力项目”的精彩项目，它完全是关于维多利亚时代的选举暴力。它记录了3000起事件
across the whole of the Victorian period. Some of them are just vandalism and some of them are proper riots. There were 96 deaths. I so approve of scholars doing this. Yeah. This is a good use of taxpayers' money. It really is. This is a genuinely good use, I think. I applaud this project. So on the 12th of July in Cheltenham, 1865, a labourer called William Lyons is walking down the street. He's been working as a sort of a messenger for the Liberal candidates. He's called Colonel Barclay.
在整个维多利亚时代。其中一些只是破坏公物，一些是真正的骚乱。有96人死亡。我非常赞成学者们这样做。是的。这是纳税人钱的好用途。确实是。我认为这确实是一个真正好的用途。我为这个项目鼓掌。所以1865年7月12日在切尔滕纳姆，一个叫威廉·莱昂斯的劳工走在街上。他一直作为自由党候选人的信使工作。他叫巴克莱上校。
And he and this other volunteer are walking down the street and they pass a band. And the band is playing a Scottish ballad called The Bonnets of blue and lines this guy he's very enthusiastic about the liberals you know he can't get enough of the liberals the liberal color is yellow so he starts singing and he sings hurrah for the bonnets of yellow you know in this jolly liberal way he loves the yellow he loves the liberals he's happy with life and passing him is a chemist called john glass john thomas glass who's a very very keen conservative and he hears this bloke
他和这个志愿者走在街上，他们经过一个乐队。乐队正在演奏一首名为《蓝色的帽子》的苏格兰民谣，莱昂斯这个家伙，他对自由党非常热情，你知道，他怎么也爱不够自由党，自由党的颜色是黄色，所以他开始唱歌，他唱着“为黄色的帽子欢呼”，你知道，以这种快乐的自由党方式，他喜欢黄色，他喜欢自由党，他对生活很满意，经过他身边的是一个叫约翰·格拉斯的化学家，约翰·托马斯·格拉斯，他是一个非常非常热心的保守党人，他听到这个家伙
singing this and he comes over and i quote interferes with him i don't know what that means but something happens they have an argument and lines is still very jolly but it's good humor banter yeah line says listen i listen, I love the Liberals. I've worked really hard for them today. And he finishes, he says, you know, cuddle Barclay forever. And at that, the chemist, Glass, he says, here's Barclay for you, you.
唱歌，他走过来，我引用，“干扰他”。我不知道那是什么意思，但发生了一些事情，他们争论起来，莱昂斯仍然非常快乐，但这是一种幽默的玩笑。是的，莱昂斯说，听着，我听着，我爱自由党。我今天为他们工作得很辛苦。他最后说，你知道，永远支持巴克莱。在那时，那个化学家，格拉斯，他说，这就是巴克莱给你的，你这个……
And then the newspaper reports blank out the last word, so we don't know what he said. But he took out a revolver and shot this bloke in the mouth. What? No. Yeah. My God. That escalated quickly.
然后报纸报道把最后一个词涂黑了，所以我们不知道他说了什么。但他拿出一把左轮手枪，对着这个家伙的嘴开了一枪。什么？不。是的。天哪。那升级得很快。
It did. And at that, in very Shakespearean style, lines then said, Good God, I am shot. I shall die. And he'd been shot in the mouth and he's still saying this. Good God. As his brain starts dribbling out through his lips. But then Glass, the man who had shot him in the mouth, then said incredibly implausibly.
确实。在那时，以非常莎士比亚的风格，莱昂斯然后说，天哪，我中枪了。我要死了。他嘴里中枪了，他还在说这个。天哪。当他的大脑开始从嘴唇流出来时。但随后格拉斯，那个朝他嘴里开枪的人，然后说得极其不可信。
I don't know the tone of voice to adopt for this. He said, I'm dying to know what he said. My God, I hope it's not as bad as all that. Well, he just shot him in the mouth. Yeah. It's just a scratch. It's but a surface wound. I hope it's not as bad as all that.
我不知道该用什么语气来说这个。他说，我太想知道他说了什么了。天哪，我希望没那么糟糕。嗯，他刚朝他嘴里开了一枪。是的。这只是擦伤。这只是表面伤口。我希望没那么糟糕。
Why did you shoot him in the mouth? I mean, that's mad. It's too late for that, isn't it? Yeah. Glass is arrested. Yeah. Lines was taken to hospital and he died. I'm not surprised.
你为什么要朝他嘴里开枪？我的意思是，那太疯狂了。现在太晚了，不是吗？是的。格拉斯被捕了。是的。莱昂斯被送往医院，他死了。我不感到惊讶。
And tragically, tragically, Tom, I feel bad about laughing now, is he left a wife, a pregnant wife and four children. And a fund was set up to support the widow and the orphans. The Liberal candidate donated generously, which is very good. Now, here's the mad thing. Mr Glass, at his trial, there was a lot of discussion about whether he was mad. He does sound a bit bonkers. He was charged with murder, but the jury reduced it to manslaughter. He served 15 years penal servitude. Why was he let off so lightly? Because in the press and the trial, everybody said,
悲剧的是，悲剧的是，汤姆，我现在因为笑而感到难过，他留下了一个妻子，一个怀孕的妻子和四个孩子。人们设立了一个基金来支持遗孀和孤儿。自由党候选人慷慨捐赠，这非常好。现在，疯狂的事情是，格拉斯先生，在他的审判中，有很多关于他是否疯了的讨论。他听起来确实有点疯狂。他被控谋杀，但陪审团将其减为过失杀人。他服了15年苦役。为什么他被判得这么轻？因为在媒体和审判中，每个人都说，
you can't blame a man. He was suffering from election excitement. And election excitement will addle your brain and you will shoot people in the mouth. So, you know, don't judge him too harshly, I think was the lesson there. It does seem there's something going on in that story. There's some detail we're missing because it seemed to escalate very quickly and then to de-escalate unusually quickly. Well, but it might just be, as you say, election madness. Election madness. So Tom, I enjoyed that so much that we took too long over it.
你不能责怪一个人。他患有“选举兴奋症”。选举兴奋症会让你大脑混乱，你会朝人们的嘴里开枪。所以，你知道，不要对他太苛刻，我想那是那里的教训。那个故事里似乎确实发生了一些事情。有一些细节我们漏掉了，因为它似乎升级得很快，然后又异常迅速地降级。嗯，但这可能正如你所说，是选举疯狂。选举疯狂。所以汤姆，我太喜欢那个故事了，以至于我们花了太长时间。
And we've got two more stories and we'll deal with them very quickly. So first Bolton. So we had a bit of liberal victimhood. Now we've got two more stories and we'll deal with them very quickly. So first Bolton. So we had a bit of liberal victimhood. Now we've got liberal misbehavior. Bolton, 1868, Gladstone's first win over Disraeli. Basically what happened in Bolton was that the liberals disgraced themselves. They discovered where conservative voters lived. They kidnapped them.
我们还有两个故事，我们会很快处理它们。所以首先是博尔顿。所以我们有了一点自由党的受害者心态。现在我们还有两个故事，我们会很快处理它们。所以首先是博尔顿。所以我们有了一点自由党的受害者心态。现在我们有了自由党的不当行为。博尔顿，1868年，格莱斯顿首次战胜迪斯雷利。基本上博尔顿发生的事情是自由党人丢了脸。他们发现了保守党选民住在哪里。他们绑架了他们。
They detained them in a mill, Thomas Barlow's mill. And then they, and I quote, supplied them with drink until their senses were stupefied. And then if they were drunk enough, they were dragged down to the polls and forced to vote conservative. But if they weren't drunk and they were still sticking to their liberal principles, they were held prisoner in the mill to stop them voting. So this went on for days. Monday the 2nd of November, some of the people held prisoner in the mill went to the windows and shouted for help and pleaded with the townsfolk to come and rescue them. When people came to try and rescue them, they discovered that, and I quote, a group of roughs said to be Irishmen armed with sticks were guarding the mill and there was a sort of pitched battle before these men could be rescued. And it does seem kind of plausible because, of course, the liberals would be the party that if you're Irish, an Irish immigrant working in Lancashire, you're probably more likely to support them than the Tories. Well, you're definitely more likely to support them than the Tories. So it kind of makes sense. The bizarre thing about this story was that Thomas Barlow, who owned the mill where all these Tory voters were held prisoner, he must have been in on it.
他们把他们关在一家工厂里，托马斯·巴洛的工厂。然后他们，我引用，“供应他们酒，直到他们的感官麻木。”然后如果他们喝得够醉，他们就被拖到投票站，被迫投保守党的票。但如果他们没喝醉，仍然坚持他们的自由党原则，他们就被关在工厂里以阻止他们投票。所以这种情况持续了几天。112月2日星期一，一些被关在工厂里的人走到窗前大声求救，恳求镇民来救他们。当人们来试图救他们时，他们发现，我引用，“一群据说是带着棍棒的爱尔兰粗人正在守卫工厂，在这些人被救出之前发生了一场混战。”这看起来确实有点可信，因为，当然，如果你是爱尔兰人，一个在兰开夏郡工作的爱尔兰移民，你可能比托利党人更倾向于支持他们。嗯，你绝对比托利党人更倾向于支持他们。所以这很有道理。这个故事离奇的地方在于，托马斯·巴洛，拥有所有这些托利党选民被关押的工厂的人，他一定参与其中。
His brother was the mayor of the town and the Wesleyan Methodist temperance campaigner and Sunday school teacher. Because I was going to say, the liberals of the temperance party. They are the temperance party. The mayor of the town is a big temperance man, Sunday school teacher, and he'd supposedly paid for the roughs to come and imprison these Tories. It's the making of a very good Sunday evening drama there. Sort of Call the Midwife-ish kind of drama.
他的兄弟是镇长，也是卫理公会禁酒运动者和主日学校老师。因为我正要说，禁酒党的自由党人。他们是禁酒党。镇长是一个大禁酒主义者，主日学校老师，他据称付钱给那些粗人来监禁这些托利党人。那里有制作一部非常好的周日晚上剧的素材。有点像《呼叫助产士》那样的剧。
Yeah. But with forced alcoholism and roughs. God, Jeremy Thorpe would enjoy that story. And then my other favourite one comes from Islington West in 1886. So the Liberal Party is split. Here in Islington West, it's a battle between Liberal Unionists, so they're basically going to become Conservatives in the long run, and Liberals. And the Liberal Unionist incumbent, Richard Chamberlain, is going to hold a really big
是的。但有强迫酗酒和粗人。天哪，杰里米·索普会喜欢那个故事。然后我另一个最喜欢的故事来自1886年的伊斯灵顿西区。所以自由党分裂了。在这里，在伊斯灵顿西区，这是自由统一党人（他们基本上长期来看会成为保守党人）和自由党人之间的战斗。而自由统一党的现任议员理查德·张伯伦，要举行一个非常大的
meeting to rally support for his candidacy. And his former Liberal allies hate him now. So they advertise his meeting in the Palma Gazette and they say, this is going to be an absolute carnage. Come and see the sport. I mean, they're literally hiring roughs to come and disrupt this bloke's meeting. Roughs, a tremendous feature of English elections. Yeah. I think roughs basically are, you know, you now see them running amok in German towns during football tournaments. Surely they're the heavies that we talked about in our episode on British fascism.
会议来争取对他候选资格的支持。而他以前的自由党盟友现在恨他。所以他们在《帕尔马公报》上为他的会议做广告，他们说，这绝对是一场大屠杀。来看看这场运动。我的意思是，他们实际上是在雇佣粗人来破坏这个家伙的会议。粗人，英格兰选举的一个巨大特征。是的。我认为粗人基本上是，你知道，你现在看到他们在足球锦标赛期间在德国城镇横行霸道。他们肯定是我们关于英国法西斯主义那一集中谈到的打手。
Yeah. Employed on both sides. Yes, exactly. That's exactly it, yeah. The Cable Street thing. Because Mosley employs boxers, didn't he? Yeah. I think a rough evolves into a heavy.
是的。双方都雇佣了。是的，完全是。那正是它，是的。电缆街事件。因为莫斯利雇佣了拳击手，不是吗？是的。我认为粗人进化成了打手。
Yeah, of course. So the meeting hasn't even really started. Mr Chamberlain appears. And as soon as he appears at this packed hall in Islington, men rush the stage. And one guy who's gone to see the talk, he's actually genuinely interested in politics. The one person there who is genuinely interested in politics, a man called Dr. Slater. He's hit on the head with the chair and he manages to sort of fend off the chair.
是的，当然。所以会议甚至还没有真正开始。张伯伦先生出现了。他一出现在伊斯灵顿这个挤满人的大厅里，男人们就冲向舞台。有一个去听讲座的家伙，他实际上对政治真的很感兴趣。那里唯一一个真正对政治感兴趣的人，一个叫斯莱特医生的人。他被椅子打中了头，他设法挡开了椅子。
And then the man who's hit him on the head with the chair punches him in the arms and the head. And there's just general chaos. And this man is eventually dragged out. The police break up the meeting and they get this man in particular. And this man, he's dumbstruck to have been arrested. He thinks this is total injustice. Infringement of his liberties as a freeborn Englishman. He's an 18-year-old joiner called Arthur Brighty. And in court, the policeman says to Brighty,
然后那个用椅子打他头的人打他的胳膊和头。到处都是混乱。这个人最终被拖了出去。警察驱散了会议，他们抓住了这个人。这个人，他被捕了感到目瞪口呆。他认为这是完全的不公正。侵犯了他作为一个自由出生的英国人的自由。他是一个18岁的细木工，叫亚瑟·布莱蒂。在法庭上，警察对布莱蒂说，
they said to Brighty, why did you go to this liberal versus liberal unionist kind of meeting? And he said, well, I have no interest in politics at all. He says, I went there with a lot more thinking to have a Barney. I'd read about it in the newspaper. There was going to be a big fight. And the judge said, well, normally you'd get a fine, but I'm not going to fine you because I know other people will pay your fine. Meaning liberals, that liberals would pay your fine because they're up to no good. So poor old Mr. Brighty gets sentenced to a month's imprisonment with hard labor, which
他们对布莱蒂说，你为什么要参加这种自由党对自由统一党的会议？他说，嗯，我对政治一点兴趣都没有。他说，我带着更多想去打一架的想法去了那里。我在报纸上读到过。会有一场大仗。法官说，嗯，通常你会得到罚款，但我不会罚你，因为我知道其他人会替你付罚款。意思是自由党人，自由党人会替你付罚款，因为他们没安好心。所以可怜的布莱蒂先生被判处一个月监禁，并进行苦役，这
seems quite harsh to me for just hitting a man on the head with a chair. But I'm, you know, I don't mind a little bit of a public disorder in elections. Yeah. You're soft on crime. That's your problem. Soft on crime. Now, you contrast that with Ed Davey. You talked about Ed Davey, the Liberal leader.
对我来说似乎太严厉了，仅仅因为用椅子打了一个人的头。但我，你知道，我不介意选举中有一点公共混乱。是的。你对犯罪太软弱了。那是你的问题。对犯罪软弱。现在，你把它和埃德·戴维对比一下。你谈到了埃德·戴维，自由党领袖。
There's not much of hitting people on, I mean, it's just falling off amusement park rides. Or flumes and things. Yeah, flumes. And we may be discussing that in our second episode, don't we? We may be. I mean, it's worth saying, Tom, obviously electoral violence is no joke. We've had two MPs lose their lives in the last few years. And we've had an MP stand down because of in the last few years and we've had an MP
没有多少打人的事，我的意思是，只是从游乐园的游乐设施上掉下来。或者水槽之类的东西。是的，水槽。我们可能会在第二集中讨论这个问题，不是吗？我们可能会。我的意思是，值得一说的是，汤姆，显然选举暴力不是开玩笑的。过去几年我们有两名议员失去了生命。过去几年我们有议员因为……我们有议员
stand down because of threats of violence against him exactly exactly so I don't want to sort of make light of it too much Rosie Duffield a Labour MP in Canterbury has cancelled going to hustings yeah I think because she's worried about violence so yeah so it is a kind of undertow but I do lament the decline in sort of the beer drinking, ribbon wearing. Let's face it, rotten cat throwing. Rotten cat throwing and people being chaired through the town and then the chairs ripped apart. I'd like to see that return. Or people being tied to poles.
因为对他的人身暴力威胁而辞职，完全完全，所以我不想太轻描淡写。罗西·达菲尔德，坎特伯雷的一名工党议员，取消了参加竞选活动，是的，我想是因为她担心暴力。所以是的，所以这是一种暗流，但我确实哀叹那种喝啤酒、戴丝带的活动的衰落。面对现实吧，扔烂猫。扔烂猫，人们被抬着穿过城镇，然后椅子被撕碎。我想看到那种回归。或者人们被绑在杆子上。
Yeah, that I could live with. And also that sort of, I think it's reasonable that if people wanted to have a battle on a heath, like in 1698 or 1705 or something. There should be room in the English constitution, the British constitution for that, don't you think? Would you go so far as to bring back Halberds? I'd bring back Halberds, the pot business. I can't remember what that's called now. Yeah. And the faggot vote.
是的，那个我可以接受。还有那种，我认为如果人们想在荒地上打一仗，就像1698年或1705年那样，这是合理的。英国宪法，英国宪法中应该有空间，你不觉得吗？你会走得那么远去带回长戟吗？我会带回长戟，那种敲锅的生意。我不记得那叫什么了。是的。还有“法戈特”选票。
I think I'd bring back all those things. You know me, I would restrict the franchise as tightly as possible. Okay. Dominic, that was great. I mean, it does make election sound brilliant. The fact that you never know when a pot is going to be banged or someone's going to be
我想我会带回所有那些东西。你知道我，我会尽可能严格地限制选举权。好的。多米尼克，那太棒了。我的意思是，它确实让选举听起来很精彩。你永远不知道什么时候会敲锅，或者有人会被
trussed up on a stick or a halberd's brought out Yeah But modern elections they can be very lively as well I think this general feeling that the one we're going through at the moment
捆在棍子上，或者长戟被拿出来。是的，但现代选举它们也可以非常活跃。我认为这种普遍的感觉，我们目前正在经历的那个
has been quite dull hasn't been a great amount of comic action Yeah so boring But over what the past 40, 50 years there's been
一直很沉闷，没有太多的喜剧动作。是的，太无聊了。但在过去40、50年里，一直有
some tremendous elections So in our next episode we will be looking at the history of recent elections. So that's John Prescott punching a bloke with a mullet, Neil Kinnock all writing at his Sheffield rally. Oh, yeah. All that kind of thing. Great film. So we hope you enjoyed it.
一些了不起的选举。所以在下一集中，我们将回顾最近选举的历史。所以那是约翰·普雷斯科特打了一个留着鲻鱼头的家伙，尼尔·基诺克在谢菲尔德集会上大喊大叫。哦，是的。所有那些东西。伟大的电影。所以我们希望你喜欢它。
Bye bye. Bye bye. I'm Marina Hyde and I'm Richard Osman and together we host The Rest Is Entertainment it's your weekly fix of entertainment news reviews
再见。再见。我是玛丽娜·海德，我是理查德·奥斯曼，我们一起主持《剩下的就是娱乐》，这是你每周的娱乐新闻评论。
splash of showbiz gossip and on our Q&A we pull back the curtain on entertainment and we tell you how it all works we have just launched our members club if you want ad free listening
一点演艺圈的八卦，在我们的问答环节中，我们将揭开娱乐界的幕后，告诉你这一切是如何运作的。我们刚刚推出了会员俱乐部，如果你想收听无广告的内容，
bonus episodes and early access to live tickets, head to therestisentertainment.com. That's therestisentertainment.com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
以及获得额外剧集和现场门票的优先购买权，请前往 therestisentertainment.com。网址是 therestisentertainment.com。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。